[Music]
in two technical news serious business
here
what is technical heavy hmm submitted by
char sway one of my good friends that's
her last name and she said its way so
that's a change so she knew what she was
talking about no that's a change well
then a mom is shocked by the reason her
daughter's sweatshirt violated her
schools dress code Oh a technicality oh
this is gonna be annoying sleeve was too
this much too short or something I just
imagined Mean Girls when she cut the
nipples out you know I was like wait a
minute no the mother would understand
that's not okay at our school we had
like spaghetti strap because spaghetti
straps are really popular and so I was
like it couldn't be thinner than like
two fingers right I remember that
two fingers yeah so this takes place in
Utah and this teen was forced to change
out of her sweatshirt because there was
an image of Marilyn Monroe and she who
was violating the dress code shoulder
what is this a Catholic school no no I
love it
well it's Utah so it's probably a Mormon
Oh Utah
oh my god I know that June it was a
religious school but there's just a lot
I mean like a lot of people in that area
are Mormon I don't know oh my god can we
get a petty scale like on a scale of one
to ten how petty was that are you told
Earl I'm gonna take like Marilyn Monroe
doesn't go to that school
I know write her up what do they think
Aaron iturra like start uprising cuz
it's like Maryland like Marilyn inspired
me to do it they're gonna be like right
no subtracting the boys that's why the
the whole school thing exists for girls
so [ __ ] stupid is stupid what I'm
wondering is do they have art history
class and then do all of those images of
like naked lady's titties out all of
that is that against school codes these
shoulders are covered the titties are
yeah that shoulder is giving me boner
that's true that is she though many
people boners is it like a halter top I
think it's a it's like Photoshop thing
cuz she's next to Tupac Oh her sleeve is
just like kind of off the shoulder yes a
cure in history I've seen it before
yeah so this team she loves Marilyn
Monroe like she has like a whole bunch
of shirts and sweaters of her image but
then this is this girl is 13 by the way
and so that's when the Vice Principal
was like nah you need to go change that
violates the dress code and she was like
what the hell so [ __ ] when she went home
she mom without me yeah and then so the
mom went to the school to talk to the
school about this and then that's when
the principal explained that Marilyn
Monroe was not in compliance with dress
code because she had exposed shoulders
both shoulders at school and since
Monroe was wearing well what she was
wearing was not within the school dress
but this [ __ ] just said that students
can wear Monroe is not a [ __ ] student
with Tupac shoulders showing boys he
sure
I can't tell okay fine
I like how the principal's awake when
this happened he felt the authority he's
like I'm the principal you're the
student you got to do this blah blah and
then like a few hours later then when
the mom comes like it's like hi I've got
to talk about that weird thing you just
did he was like [ __ ] that was kind of
weird I've got to justify it
double down yeah yeah gonna double down
on it maybe he was turned on by Marilyn
Monroe oh yeah me too yes it is on a 32
haven't had sex with my wife at nine
years what man
when bro was definitely a hussy so was
he like damn this hussy is turning me on
and I want to cuss he influenced him
maybe this Marilyn is inappropriate in
general for a 13 year old in his eyes
maybe but she was okay
and that's also kind of who likes
Marilyn Monroe growing up though who
started the trend of girls looking up to
like always mixing girls about my school
[Laughter]
first time Nicky has ever just shut up
he felt insular like he's a shut up
just walking around right now he just
gets all like Nikki's pushback on an
argument a very effeminate male okay
like I said the Mexicans took that one
alright so I don't know the crazy meds
make the Mex and the cholas in my school
they all know City right - in my school
- we had a show cave fire crews [ __ ] cuz
the offensive [ __ ] that excuses their
[ __ ] that says like if you can't handle
me at my worst you don't deserve being
my best and it's always finger on a
sweater before tumblr yeah exactly say
more of the tumblr yeah and we also take
ownership of Tinkerbell alright so y'all
got our Instagram was it was just us
taking disposable camera pictures and
putting it in our binders like in the
clear binders day to like decorate the
binder from the outside on the inside
yeah we had a theme okay we started that
all we're nerds I'm sorry I didn't do
anything
wow you're cool just to take pictures
that's like that because I didn't have
friends and I even have a binder yeah I
have friends on the Internet on the
message board the ones who didn't have
friends well that is they're like candy
wrappers and [ __ ] like takis wrapper oh
yeah that's really in the binder I have
pictures of me and my cat Oh cute I felt
sad for a second work binder decorated
my binder because I usually didn't bring
it I usually also wasn't there hybl
because I had no friends but like next
level I thought everyone hated me so I
was like I just won't go today oh yeah I
would just like skip and then wait for
my mom to go to work and then go back
home dude see my not used to check my
room every morning to make sure I with
the school so I would go hide and sleep
the closet until I hear the front door
closed and they go back to bed oh my god
yes yes no binders here dog get through
high school then yeah I was I got kicked
out of three different schools and then
I finally went to an alternative school
that had a lot of online like one line
classes so I took those from home and
then I graduate around like 16 oh yeah I
would go to school and then ditch so
like there was some teachers that I got
really good grades and so a lot of
teachers were really chill and there was
like a 7-eleven and a Costco and all
this stuff like right like over the hill
from our school so I would be like I
gotta go the bathroom and then I would
just go chill it like get 7-eleven go go
chill it cause marques attend
go to the Barnes & Noble yeah yeah
yeah it would go first - and then I
would leave yeah but yeah anyway so this
girl here so the vice-principal was the
one that was tripping over her
sweatshirt but then when the mom finally
talked to the principal because I said
principal earlier but that's still the
vice principal principal said that no
he's actually gonna have to go over the
dress code policy with the school staff
because the teachers are just going and
bringing their an opinion because that
has nothing to do with the dress oh my
god was the vice principal a woman not
that I know of
oh you were looking for a little bit of
like well because I happened to me so
the vice principal at my school was a
lady and she like I think she like was
kind of miffed that she was not the
principal or something I don't know she
would always like kind of have to use
her power her like assert authority
right and I was like such a good student
right I got straight A's but um she left
she would walk past the I would wear
like punk rock clothes like so I looked
like maybe not a bad not a good student
and she would walk past these
cheerleaders that are wearing tiny ass
little skirts like tiny ass little tank
tops breaking school rules like crazy
and she would like go to me and be like
you can't it was cool to like tighten
your shirt t-shirt by putting like a
like you tighten it with a rubber band
well people don't do that anymore I
don't know if they do that for that so
she's like you have to take your shirt
down I was like whatever so I did and
then later in the day I put it back up
and she's like I told you at lunch time
to take it down and she took me out of
school and then like into into what's it
called the detention like basically
detention but during school hours I was
like I have to take a test right now
like I'm gonna miss my history test
she's like I don't care I told you know
in-school suspension an in-school
suspension yeah and I was like I was
crying because I was missing this test
and it was I thought I was gonna affect
my grade they didn't give you the test
here
no I did I can't read it I really cared
and she was like she took me out of
class because that like that class was
actually the essential class I would
ditch like the elective classes you know
and so yeah she would she took me out of
class and she took my bracelet because
she said that it might hurt somebody was
it it was like studs it wasn't like
spikes it was like square ones and I was
like hurt someone with your earring more
than that bracelet we're any of you guys
I just had PTSD where any of you guys
ever on ISS know what's up it it was
worse like you get suspended for
anything you would normally just go home
and you're like oh and then your parents
are real mad at you so there was some
punishment in it but in in-school
suspension they would put us in a
trailer and we just all have desks and
there was a security guard and you were
not allowed to talk for eight hours and
they would just give you what no I did
Saturday school and son I did Saturday
school once too I forged my mom's
signature because she told me to but
they caught me so then even though they
talk to you didn't talk to your mom like
well she had a sign for it so my mom was
like just like faking my signature and
pretend it it's me I'm like okay and
then they like caught me they're like
this doesn't look like your other mom
the other no did your mom explain yeah
but they didn't care cuz forgery is like
not chill they should put your mom's
pension imagine if they made if you made
it weird like well yeah my parents are
divorced because my dad cheated on my
mom and now she's a wreck and I was a
new lady oh my god just freak him out Oh
lately I'm trying to imagine like if I
try to forge any one signature now it
would be a hot mess so what made me
think
yeah yeah my crayon mimicking good you
actually think like oh man yeah this
looks good this looks good there's no
[ __ ] way that was believable there's
absolutely no way I had my friend fake a
report card for me once and now that I
think about it when I got trouble in
trouble for it I looked at I'm like damn
I'm dumb as [ __ ] cuz they look terrible
it wasn't even on the right paper I
don't even think they spelled part of it
wrong right Wow wait would you have
Saturday school for um I was very truant
Oh like a lot like it when I was in
elementary school my parents even had to
go to court because of how many times I
was like oh my god was that you was that
you want some thug [ __ ] or yeah I was
like your parents my parents that was
Lupita not today were very irresponsible
because they were the ones taking me to
school I was in elementary school and
then it had led to the point where the
the court had settled then you had to go
to Saturday school for like it's about
so what I'm talking about now is when I
was younger but then in high school I
was still like my whole school career I
was just always late oh and by the time
it was not your very on time uh kind of
not really I mean I did improve from
when I was in school but I'm not like
the best I'm not like super early every
time mm-hmm
I try
[Music]
[Music]